oui vous êtes là vous pourriez nous dire
quelques mots sur darry cowl vous qui
parlez tellement bien les morts au moins
dix vivent encore ma j'ai la chance de
mon premier film j'ai fait avec lui
c'était l'ami de la famille et ligoté le
triporteur
le treport patrie botteur triporteur
c'était après mais c'était un il était
plein de c'est un lutin c'était un
enfant il jouait beaucoup carte au
casino ils adorent et les femmes il
était amoureux de béatrice altarriba
mais amoureux comme un étudiant comme un
enfant ils portaient des fleurs il veut
acheter les petits cadeaux des bagues il
était délicieux parce que il tremblait
pour lui qui voulait lui plaire alors il
a pesé rire beaucoup c'est ce qui était
sa preuve ce principe à sélection je
crois que jusqu'au bout de sa vie il a
fait croire à sa femme qu'il était
internet ce qui est la plus belle preuve
d'amour